what is chicken picking you often hear
this term associated with country guitar
and simply put all all chicken picking
is is it's a style of hybrid picking
that allows us to to pluck the strings
uh with a certain kind of attack and
feel and what what hybrid picking means
is that you're using a a pick in this
case I'm using just a regular pick uh
other players will will use a thumb pick
which we'll talk about in a bit um but
you're using a a pick in combination
with your fingers so we're not just uh
straight picking all the notes we're
actually going to be using uh a hybrid
or a combination of our fingers and the
pick and this allows us to do some or to
get sounds like this that you would you
would be hard press to get if you were
just using a pick alone let me let me
demonstrate it allows us to get rhythms
like
[Music]
this and it allows us to play double
stop licks like
[Music]
[Applause]
this so overall it's a it's a very
useful technique to develop uh it does
take some time to get under your fingers
if it's brand new to you if you've never
used your fingers in conjunction with a
pick before uh it is going to take some
time but it is it is well worth it it's
almost like a superp power once you
unlock it because it it allows you to do
so much more on the guitar so all that
being said how can we learn to chicken
pick so to begin with we need a a pick
obviously and I'm using just a regular
old flat pick um any style of pick will
work you will also see some of the
greatest guys to ever do this using
thumb picks um and I I cannot do the
thumbpick thing there's there's benefits
there there's pros and cons to to both
of these Styles and I'll kind of get
into that briefly but I would say if
you're coming from a maybe a blues or a
rock background and you're already used
to using just a regular pick I would not
recommend jumping to a thumb pick just
because it's the whole thing is going to
seem so foreign the the benefit of using
a thumb pick is it leaves our pointer
finger which is our most Dex dextrous
dexterous
dexterous I don't know it's the most
useful finger maybe I'm going to have to
look that word up uh but the the whole
thing with a thumb pick is it leaves our
our pointer finger and our ring finger
available to do the the
popping so a lot of people like that cuz
because they feel the most comfortable
using their their pointer finger if we
jump to a a regular pick we we tie up
our pointer finger obviously holding the
pick now we have to use our uh middle
finger and our ring finger in
conjunction to kind of get those extra
notes that we want so not uh not a right
or wrong answer here Brent Mason is
probably one of the not probably he's
one of the best players to ever play
this this style and he uses a thumbpick
um
the I guess the other downside of a
thumb pick I don't know if you can
alternate pick quite as quickly with a
thumb pick just because the upstroke if
you're doing an upstroke with a thumb
pick you still have to kind of marry
your finger to it otherwise it starts to
catch on the
strings all that being said do what do
what feels most comfortable to you if
you're brand new to all of this maybe
try them both and see what you like more
um I'm going to be showing it with a
regular pick but that's just my
preference it's not the right way to Do
It um yeah so that's kind of the first
step we need to get the pick the Second
Step we're going to start adding uh
we're going to start adding our
fingers so we have our pick step two
we're going to start using our fingers
uh and the the question not the question
but a question I get a lot of the time
is do you need fingernails in order to
play this style um the answer is no the
the whole there's a few reasons people
get fingernails uh uh one is they they
want their fingers to
sound the same as a pick if that makes
sense so that you don't hear different
sounds whether you're picking with a
pick or with your fingers um but the the
main point of this style is we want that
pop which I'm going to talk about here
in a second but I think people find it
easier to get that pop if they have a
little bit more of a nail to to grab the
string with so once again this is going
to be a muscle memory thing I think it's
maybe a little bit easier to learn with
if you grow your fingernails out just a
tiny bit but it is not a requirement um
I'll show you here in a second I have my
fingernails are cut super short so not a
requirement at all once again try it
maybe grow them out for a few weeks and
and see if you like that better but not
not necessary so now that we're now that
we're adding the fingers let's let's
learn our first
lick make sure that you stick around
till the end of the video because I'm
going to be putting all of these ideas
is into an actual solo so that you can
hear how it sounds in the in the context
of an actual song in addition all the
the tabs to the the licks and the solo
as well as the backing track for that
solo that stuff is all available over on
patreon so if that's something you're
interested if that is something you're
interested in definitely go go check it
out over there so the first lick we're
learning is is going to be super easy
and it's not meant to be musical this is
strictly just to get this kind of idea
under your fingers so we're going to do
this thinking key of key of D
here uh and I'm going to start up here
on the uh what is that the seventh fret
and I'm I'm using my pick on the D
string and then I'm just kind of resting
my my middle finger on the G string here
and my my ring finger is resting on the
B string so when it comes time for one
of my fingers to do its work it's
already kind of laying on the string
that it's then supposed to to pick so
I'm going to start with just
picking and we can you can kind of pick
whatever notes you want on the the
adjacent string we're we're just working
on getting our pick and our fingers
working together so for the sake of this
I'll just pick once and hammer
on and then I want us to start just
getting that
Pop um so we can just go back and
[Music]
forth and if you'll you'll see here I'm
kind of over exaggerating but we really
want to kind of get our finger under
that string and pop like pull it up so
that it slams back into the the Frets
and that's what's giving us that that
chicken picking
pop uh the AL alternative would be if
you're just kind of playing more
[Music]
mellow which there's certainly a time
and place for uh even within country
style picking but to really get that
that percussive snap we have to almost
lift the string up a bit so that it it
pops back into the
Frets so just if if if you're brand new
to this this is a good thing to just
kind of work on picking a string and
then plucking a string with your finger
once you've done it with your middle
finger work on just adding it or uh
skipping and then going to your your
ring finger this one's going to feel
even more weird if you're new to this
so when I'm doing this picking um I'm
trying to grab the
string I'm I'm I'm trying to grab the
string right basically where my
fingernail makes connection to the the
Flesh of of the
finger so I'm kind of angling it
sideways and using that to to to grab
the string and pop it out so if I did
have more of a fingernail that's where
it would help help me kind of grab I'd
be like almost reaching my fingernail
under the string to to grab it
there so like I said this isn't a super
musical lick it's just kind of a a
phrase to start getting this under your
finger so once you've done that a few
times we're going to now make it sound
somewhat country we're going to add a
bend in here so we're going to start the
same
[Music]
way so if you see there uh I'm I'm I'm
starting with that hammer
on and then I
uh I am uh using my middle finger on
that the G string
there and then I'm immediately putting
my middle finger back down and and
plucking It
Again full step
Bend then here's my ring finger on the B
string middle finger again
and then I'm ending with a a picked note
using my pick on that that uh root note
that D
[Music]
there um so that's a that's a a great
musical lick that we can now start using
in a kind of a musical context
[Music]
that's going to be the first lick that
now incorporates both of our fingers the
the final lick kind of for the the
fingers working independently we're
going to be doing it all on the same
string
so uh it's it's going to sound something
like this
[Music]
so still thinking key of D here and I'm
just walking up from that
third to our fifth
chromatically but every time if you
notice I'm I'm alternating between a pck
note and then plucking with that middle
finger so I'm actually picking while
it's
muted and then I'm pressing down and
plucking it
[Music]
I I kind of find when students are first
starting to do this that doing it on the
same string gets a little bit more
complicated cuz the the pick and your
figure are getting in the way of each
other but it it can give us kind of a
cool unique sound um when we do it like
that on the same string that it's tough
to get with just using a pick so it's
it's another valuable thing to practice
is working with the the chicken picking
style all within one one
string so let's talk about um using our
fingers in tandem now for like double
stop ideas and the way I like to think
about this um is just resting them on
the the fretboard and then just kind of
marrying them together so that when they
when they pick the strings they're
they're coming off at the same
[Music]
time so for for this double stop lick
we're going to do it in the the key of D
again we're going to start kind of
similar but we're now going to be uh
kind of adding that that that double
stop feel so um D major again we're
going to do
[Music]
this and all I'm doing there is I'm I'm
kind of doing those approach
notes and then I'm uh like I said I'm
just resting my fingers right there uh G
string and B string and just coming off
the strings plucking them at the same
[Music]
time you you will occasionally see
people doing the double stop picking
with their pick and their middle
finger instead of their uh middle or
yeah middle and ring finger I'm a huge
fan of leaving the pick out of it when
I'm doing double stops just cuz it
allows us a lot more options for
[Music]
doing looks like that where you still
want your pick doing something else if
we're we're involving the pick in the
double stop it kind of takes it out of
the picture for then jump into other
strings so once again it's not not
necessarily right or wrong just how I
prefer to do
it once we get that under our fingers
we're going to add some more bends and
incorporate uh the Double stop with some
single single string picking so
something like
[Applause]
[Music]
this so what I'm doing
there starting exactly the
same but I'm I'm I'm picking that or
plucking then putting my fingers
immediately back on those strings to
mute them and then bending up while I
pluck that with my uh my middle
finger hit the ring
finger and then I'll probably end it
with my
pick so I'm I'm using chicken picking to
to do the first part of the
bend uh and then then I'll bring my pick
down and
finish with my pick so that one's going
to sound like
[Music]
this once we have all that under our
fingers we're starting to get
comfortable with it let's just learn one
more more kind of advanced lick that's
going to wrap all this up and and put it
all together this is a Brent Mason lick
he actually teaches it uh there's videos
of him teaching it on YouTube so I don't
feel bad for for stealing it we're going
to do this one in the key of E it's
going to sound like
[Music]
this so what is going on there uh
similar to how we started that that lick
prior that we did in D um we're kind of
doing that approach
with the double
stop then I'm just moving down a whole
step then using my pick to walk down
those those three
[Music]
notes jumping down another whole step uh
sort of the fifth fret
here and then here I'm I'm adding the
the chicken picking back
in move down one
fret and then uh after I pick that
second
I'm just sliding down one more fret so
I'm not picking once I do that slide
it's it's like
[Music]
that and one other thing I should add is
I'm I'm doing a a dead
note right
there so between that barred double stop
in this one I'm I'm kind of just resting
my middle or my ring finger here on my
fretting
hand so I'm not pressing down it's not
ringing out it's just a muted
[Music]
note that's a great one to start adding
in on solos sounds super super cool and
yeah it uses is all this stuff the last
thing um just since we're on the topic
let's just briefly talk banjo
rolls Bano rolls are just kind of within
the umbrella of chicken picking it's
just a different style within it and
Baner Ros are are cool because basically
you're going to be rolling your
fingers uh in combination with your pick
trying to basically trying to emulate
how a banjo player would would pick the
string so it allows you to get sounds
like
[Music]
this which if you were just trying to
flatpick that stuff it's it's not going
to be an option for you the the way it
rings out and the just the speed it
would require so that's kind of why I
say learning this stuff can open up like
it can be kind of a superpower Source
just because it opens up so many new
possibilities for how you can play stuff
on the guitar so just a a quick brief
int ruction to to banjo rolls that's
going to be a whole lesson on its own
someday but we kind of talked earlier
about how I just rest my my fingers on
the strings that I'm planning on picking
so for for a banjo roll um we'll just
take these three notes of a open E chord
so just d g d uh G and B
strings and I'm just I have my pick just
resting on the G or on the D string
finger on the G ring is on the G and mid
sorry middle is on the G and ring is on
the
B and I'm just kind of rolling through
them and then once I get done I just
kind of place them all back on and get
ready to do it
again and then you can just slowly speed
it up
[Music]
so we'll just work on ascending that
little uh chord progression there I'm
just going from those the that open or
the like cowboy chord E
shape to a
a to a
b back to an
E you can do it once per
position you can do it multiple times
[Music]
this is not necessarily supposed to be
super musical in the sense uh that you
would want to play it over a solo maybe
but it's more just designed to get that
that repeating muscle memory
[Music]
down anyways that is uh that is kind of
the the
entry entry dive into getting banjo
rolls down like I said that is a topic
that we could do a whole hours worth of
lessons on but if you're new to this
stuff it's useful to know that that
exists uh maybe something you want to
look into
more um cool okay so let's put all of
this together into an actual solo the
licks themselves aren't going to be used
exactly cuz I'm going to try to make
this sound Musical and cool but let's
put them all into a solo at least the
the ideas all into a solo that show okay
is how this stuff is used out in the the
real world so yeah let me uh take a
break here and write a solo cuz I don't
really have an idea of what I'm going to
do yet and we will check back in in a
second
[Music]
[Applause]
so hopefully that solo kind of helped
put into context what all this stuff
sounds like in real world application
like I said this stuff's not going to be
uh
you're not going to get it right away if
it's new to you um but it's definitely
worth investing the time to get the hang
of this stuff because yeah it just opens
up so many doors not just in within
country but within within so many genres
of music uh it just makes you that much
more versatile because you're able to
use the the extra fingers to your
advantage like that so like I said that
solo uh I'm going to break down the
whole thing and teach it kind of step
byep over on patreon if you want to more
detail in depth of what's going on there
um yeah head over to patreon and uh
check that out the backing track as well
as the PDF for all the tabs from this
lesson are over there as well
so I know I say this all the time but I
hope this is helpful for everyone um
yeah I'm just kind of trying to make the
videos that I would have wanted to see
when I was starting out so this is just
a kind of a beginner taste into or kind
of an introductory taste into what is
available with chicken picking obviously
it's a
bottomless pit as far as what you can
get into but hopefully this is helpful
hopefully this kind of gives you some
insight into what what exactly it is
um 100% need to learn this if you want
to learn country guitar that's just the
reality of it to get the the right sound
the right feel you got to be able to to
pick like this so yeah that's all I got
for you today uh as always thank you so
much for checking out the video checking
out the channel do all the stuff where
you subscribe and like and comment that
definitely definitely helps and I
definitely appreciate it and yeah take
care be good to everyone be good to
yourself and we will see you all in the
next video